here they are uh talking about Governor
understand this and again getting rid of
woke gender ideology from one
African-American studies course but look
at what they extrapolate out of that
because what they're doing with all of
these memes and schtick is they're kind
of softening up the electorate for some
really bizarre things that they want to
do Banning lgbtq books Nationwide that's
big big government
yeah it would be funny if it wasn't so
dangerous because they were in power and
they might have even more power in 2024
look on on immigration this is a party
whose most recent achievement was to
separate innocent children from their
parents many of those kids never to be
reunited again and that is actually a
policy they would likely pursue on this
Banning books issue and I've got to say
it's not just Marjorie Taylor green and
George Santos it is Ron DeSantis and
other governments but break down the
absurdity and I honestly think you got
to attack the absurdity of it first and
foremost this is a group of people I
believe reading a book can make you gay
think about it that that's their biggest
concern if you read a book you might
decide you're gay they think the
solution to what they see as societal is
is big big government it's the governor
of Florida telling you specifically what
books you can read it's the government
deciding specifically what teachers can
teach it's literal government thought
control
this is incredible this is this is
absolutely incredible today is it
because it's a Monday it's a Monday
thing or something like that every
single thing that they say is alive they
love big government control okay first
off the guy's a former Congressman so
that makes me feel good David Jolly is a
former Republican congressman who now
goes on MSNBC tells you all need all you
need to know about this guy okay so
let's uh let's just move past uh Mr
Jolly there uh the books that they are
referring to no one thinks that the book
is going to make you gay you morons what
they don't want is in many of these
books they are literally teaching kids
what apps to download to go have
anonymous sex with strangers and how to
give hand jobs and and I
suppose if you were going to have that
book in the class you could also have
Don lemon's book there are ways not to
perform oral sex by Don Lemon I suppose
if they put both of those books together
then we'd have an actual functioning
library with a diverse set of ideas but
everything they say is a Lie the state
is in control of what books you can read
that is how it works so generally
conservatives and Republicans want more
school choice for some reason these
people want pornographic books in the
kindergartens I don't know why that
would be something to ask them
[Music]